I want to start by saying I know you're
from and you live in the New York area
yes I do and you guys just went through
this terrible storm I'm reading reports
that people was very difficult for
people to vote did you vote yeah you
know the whole thing with the voting now
is that because of this you know sandy
yeah of course the hurricane sandy they
kept moving locations so like it became
kind of like this flash mob thing like
it's like okay
go down the block okay you're gonna see
a dude go up an elevator alright I'm
gonna do its apartment I don't even know
if I voted or did his laundry I'm not
exactly sure what I did that's why I
like when they cancel the marathon I was
a little depressed and you know I know a
lot of people like we shouldn't have a
marathon I'm like we should yeah you
know because like first of all we got
all these people they're amazing
athletes we should hook them up to
treadmills and let them power the city
[Applause]
okay I got next box I want to play
that's a fantastic idea well how did you
personally cope with the storm how did
you deal with it well it's pretty
difficult because you know batteries
became like money and I'm not even tell
you about gas gas is like wow
but batteries were like money and I'm
lucky because I prepped you know I'm a
prepper so I got this flashlight and you
wind it up for like an hour and a half
you know just keep winding it and it
gives you like thirty seconds of life
it's amazing just enough to see like a
guy break in your apartment
blanked out